khloe kardashian and trey songz spotted making out in Sin City do we have a new hot couple in Hollywood a source tells ET Chloe and the 31 year old R&B star were spotted partying and kissing in Vegas the two arrived together to Dre's nightclub at the Cromwell on Saturday where Trey was performing as part of the venue's live concert series the source says Chloe watched from a stage side VIP booth throughout the performance grinning from ear to ear following his performance and eyewitness spotted the pair kissing and race after hours in the early morning hours telling et quote they weren't shy about it khlomoney and Trey were first rumoured to be an item after the two were spotted getting flirty at Khloe's 32nd birthday bash in Los Angeles well if I didn't feel loved now I do for the rest of my life